greetings brave adventurers seekers of
knowledge explorers of the great unknown
no doubt by now you've heard the stories
of the noble lord theodore thomas
blackwood gentleman explorer and
naturalist also known as
scp-1867 his exploits are known far and
wide though some question the validity
of his tales due to the simple fact that
he is a neon sea slug and not a human
man
these are of course fools we have even
covered lord blackwood before in a sea
snails fantasy scp-1867
a gentleman but never before have we
taken a look at such a daring account of
his work today we discuss a most curious
hunting expedition one that brought our
lord blackwood face to face with the
great beast the hard to destroy reptile
scp-682
itself what will become of our hero what
sites will he see on his journey let us
find out tally hall on may 14 1883
months after nearly losing his life
while climbing mount everest lord
blackwood received a letter at his
london home upon opening it he saw that
it was a formal invitation from one
colonel joseph default of the french
army it invited him to participate in a
hunt for a monster known as the terracay
that threatened the lives and security
of the french people anyone who was able
to slay the creature would receive a
handsome award of 5 million pounds for
their trouble unable to resist a
challenge the chance to face off against
a creature he had never heard of before
or the allure of such an impressive
prize lord blackwood sent off an
acceptance so what was the teresque lord
blackwood's research turned up a
fearsome description it was a massive
scaly creature with a high that seemed
impossible to pierce that breathed fire
and killed everything in its path
without batting an eye a worthy foe
indeed by the end of the day lord
blackwood had received an address where
he would attend a briefing before the
hunt would commence the meeting was held
in a private room in the city in an
exclusive club there were three other
would-be hunters there mr roosevelt from
america mr dukoff from russia and mr
harris from england the colonel greeted
the man and told them what they were up
against a beast had laid waste to a
french town ripping men women and
children to shreds and resisting every
blow dealt against it by the army so the
colonel vowed to gather expert
scientists and hunters for if they could
not take down the monster it was likely
that no one could on may the 20th the
party arrived in france to begin the
great adventure each man brought his own
armaments a combination of specialized
weapons and knowledge for the task at
hand the following day the colonel
escorted the man to the quarantine zone
where the beast's attack had led it lord
blackwood was troubled by the sights
there it was a city at war soldiers
patrolled the streets and barricades
were placed at the edge of town citizens
were being evacuated as soldiers aided
them and few had seen the beasts
themselves at least they had not been
unfortunate enough to see it up close
beyond the quarantine barrier it was
hell on earth there were bodies laying
in the streets buildings burnt to the
ground castles and stone walls reduced
to piles of rubble there was not one
living thing in sight not a person a
farm animal or even so much as an insect
the men set up camp near the edge of
town and mr harris set about tracking
the beast before too long he had found
it to the southwest and the next day
they would set off after it the next day
the party made its way southwest to
belleville following a trail of
destruction there they found it having a
nap in the sun it was longer than a
whale taller than a giraffe and bigger
than both lord blackwood thought that if
it had any visible wings he would
consider it a dragon they approached it
slowly careful not to wake the teresque
lord blackwood crouched behind a fence
steadied his gun and fired right at its
head the shot hit and the top of the
teresque's head came off with its impact
it seemed as if the beast was after so
much pomp and circumstance dead right
there but sadly it was not it sprang to
life blood and brains dripping from its
open skull as it turned to the men and
roared then charged the men scattered
firing their guns as they ran the
monster gaining on them faster and
faster until mr ducat fired into its
open wound with an electric rifle it was
stunned long enough for the men to make
it onto their horses as they rode away
the monster continued to chase them new
skin and bone growing over what had once
been a hole in its skull
lord blackwood fired a particle
destabilizer at its leg tearing it off
but as he watched in horror the leg
began to grow back the hunting party
managed to escape with their lives
though their confidence was thoroughly
shaken they rested that night with the
soldiers at the barricade they attempted
to attack the teresque again the
following day but failed once more the
men realized that a simple gunshot
electrocution or fire would not be
enough to kill the monster it simply
healed too fast and its tolerance for
pain was too high in order to kill it
they realized they would have to render
it to mobile and destroy its body so
thoroughly that it would die before it
could rebuild itself and so
they decided to set a trap they dug a
massive trench wide and long enough for
the monster and deep enough that it
would not be able to climb out before
they had killed it in the bottom of the
pit they had placed hundreds of steel
spikes the tips dipped in poison they
placed a bridge across it strong enough
for the men and horses but weak enough
to break under the terrasque's weight
and covered it all with grass and leaves
now they just had to wait mr roosevelt
acted as bait approaching the monster on
horseback and attacking it with a
gunshot then running and leading it back
toward the trap as roosevelt's race
across the bridge the creature pursued
him and fell into the pit where it was
impaled on the spikes then the man
rained down hellfire they shot it with
bullets explosives jellied kerosene mr
duka fired a pitch blend gun that upon
firing released a blur of smoke and fire
once the fire had receded all that
remained was a skeleton the men took the
skull charred from the flames and
planned to take it back as a trophy
all was well or so it seemed the men
returned to the town with the monster
skull in tow and the soldiers cheered at
the site they posed for photographs and
mr dukoff decided to pose with his head
between the jaws of the beast this was a
grave mistake on his part and the jaws
closed tight around his neck his head
falling to the ground the skull acted on
its own rolling and biting all the while
growing fresh skin and scales it opened
its gaping maw and shouted
or for those of you that are not
familiar with the french language you
make me sick screams ran out behind lord
blackwood and he turned to see the rest
of the teresque's body a headless corpse
covered with stringy bits of muscle and
slowly growing brand new flesh it
stomped through the field crushing men
in tents beneath its great feet on its
way to reclaim its head mr harris ran
for the bank vault to grab a weapon he
had only referred to previously as his
secret weapon
lord blackwood chased after him and
found harris pulling a large crate which
he opened with a sense of desperation
there inside was a sarcophagus bound in
chains and covered in ancient ruins
blackwood begged harris to leave the
thing behind and run for his life but he
did not have a chance to finish before
harris opened the lid and an arm
wielding a sword emerged and sliced his
head from his body a man emerged from
the sarcophagus naked wielding a sword
covered in tattoos blackwood had no way
of knowing this but the man was none
other than the deadly warrior
scp-076 or abel the mysterious man
attacked blackwood and roosevelt and
though they tried to defend themselves
no weapon seemed to have an effect on
him he was preparing to deliver a final
blow to blackwood and kill him once and
for all when the terrorscape burst
through the wall of the building with a
mighty bellow at the sight of the
enormous monster abel turned his focus
from the two men to the beast and so the
two seemingly unkillable creatures
driven by bloodlust and inhuman strength
began to fight it took over an hour and
left destruction and death in its wake
abel armed himself with explosives
mounting them to his chest along with
the pitch blend gun and ran towards the
teresque
knowing what would come next roosevelt
and blackwood locked themselves in the
bank vault and prayed that someone would
find them before they starved to death
after two days the men were saved by a
major of the army who was leading a
group of soldiers in search for any
survivors they were taken to a hospital
and nursed back to health by the staff
there as well as a friend of blackwood's
named henry the major who rescued them
told them that the colonel was dead and
so were ten thousand others claimed by
the massive explosion the teresque and
abel had both disappeared and there was
no indication of where either of them
had gone all that was left was
destruction and the memory that a true
monster had made itself known on french
soil now the only thing left to do was
recover as best as anyone could it would
certainly take a very long time the army
was very suspicious of both roosevelt
and blackwood as the only survivors have
an explosion so large it had been seen
throughout france they demanded to know
how the two had survived and what they
had seen throughout this process an
englishman watched and took notes but
did not speak a word roosevelt and
blackwood were eventually released but
they did not receive a penny of their
promised reward and were told they could
not return to france again for the rest
of their lives they were not to speak a
word of what they had seen to anyone or
there would be dire consequences in
calais the two survivors said goodbye
and roosevelt announced he would return
to america to pursue a career in
politics who can say what happened to
him after that upon returning to his
home in london lord blackwood found that
he had received a postcard it read the
royal foundation for the security
containment and protection of anomalous
objects in phantasmagoria requests a
meeting for the purpose of negotiating
an alliance favorable to both our
parties please call anytime except
sundays at number 19 merbonne road
westminster and asked to speak to doctor
thursday your discretion is requested in
this matter he was puzzled by this note
unsure of what to make of it perhaps he
thought he could see what they had to
say after all he was always curious and
ready to explore new territory once he
had recovered sufficiently he would
reach out to this strange group and see
what they might have to offer him and so
began a new chapter of lord blackwood's
story one that included a mysterious
organization called the scp foundation
now go check out a sea snail's fantasy
scp-1867 a gentleman and
scp-682 ways the scp foundation tried to
kill the hard to destroy reptile for
more about the two anomalies featured in
today's thrilling tale